brian's in new york hey brian how can we
help
hey dude how's it going good man what's
up
oh good you know i have a funny question
um
you know i feel like i'm in i'm in a
pickle here
so i'm currently
i'm currently a student and i and i work
full-time
um but you know i i did something stupid
and i you know i ended up buying i
buying a property and i end up closing
this week
with that property
um besides
besides this property i don't have any
any other debts i paid off my car
um got a car paid off i got all my
credit cards paid off and everything
so the closing was today or it's later
in the week
later on this week so what happens if
you don't close
it's a well it's on the contract i
already
i already talked to the attorney and
they said uh once you sign this contract
and everything it's
it's all it's like done no it's not done
until you close it
a contract is you made a promise to
close how much earnest money you put up
oh five thousand okay you'll lose that
and and i have an additional ten
thousand that's due on the closing
you know you won't lose that because
you're not gonna give it to them
yeah okay so how how stupid is this you
said you did something stupid
that's what you said well was it five
thousand dollars worth of stupid
well i don't know i mean i you know my
parents are pushing me to
get out of the house and i was doing i
was
using that as a motive to get out of the
house
and it cost the same way as much as rent
so
now you're now you're arguing with
yourself you called and said i did
something stupid now you're telling me
how stupid is not stupid
was it stupid or was it
um i don't know i try to justify it yeah
yeah i think
okay justify it all right so are you
what do you make a year i make 3 200
take home um i think it's around 70 000
a year salary
okay and what is the house payment
supposed to be if you close this one um
it's supposed to be uh 1300 a month
okay all right and so
why do you think this was stupid why did
you tell me this was stupid
uh because i i still have student loans
and i'm still in school so i still have
a lot i still have a lot um more school
to go
but um i just
i just felt like you were the only
alternative since it felt like a good
alternative
um because of the price
the interest rate and everything that i
was able to get in and especially
considering that it's the same thing as
any market around where i am
okay so what's your question for us
i'm questioning to see if
i don't know what should i do i don't
know what should i do i mean i still
have a lot of student loans am i am i
okay
um no you're not okay okay you're not
okay you bought a condo you can't afford
and you're broke
you're not okay it's not like all of a
sudden i'm gonna tell you this is smart
but i'm just trying to figure out where
you're gonna go
um is it gonna bankrupt you i don't
think so
but was it a bad idea yeah definitely a
bad idea
and i guess the question i have for you
as well brian is what will you do
if you don't close will you continue to
live with your parents would you rent
like
looking through your options and your
scenarios here because it is an
interesting question because
you're at this fork in the road with
like you know a day to decide
you know you haven't closed but you got
five thousand dollars on the line you
know you're right in the middle there
how much is in your bank account um
right now at the moment it's around
twenty five thousand okay
where'd that come from um just a bunch
of savings and that's
that's considering after i paid off my
car which cost like twenty
five thousand as well
and you have a hundred thousand in
student loans yeah
yeah i have a hundred thousand student
loans yeah okay
i tried to pay off some of the items
okay so here's what you got you have two
choices
one is you walk away from a deal that
you made a promise on and you lose the
five thousand dollars they could sue you
but they won't
and you go rent an apartment and you
move out because dad's already told you
it's time to leave and he's right
okay and then you start working on your
student loans and then you save up and
buy a house later after you get our
student loan debt
of course that's what we would have
signed you up for because you knew when
you called we tell people not to buy a
house while they got student loan debt
or a bunch of other debt for that matter
you knew that that's how you started
this conversation
okay option number two is you close on
the deal you move in
and you buckle down and you say i have
no life
until i get the rest of my school paid
for
and i clear these student loans and
don't talk to me
about going on vacation because you're
special
while you're in the middle of this i
will knock you out
okay you have nothing to do but clean
get you a big shovel and shovel manure
for the next four years that's all you
get to do
because you got a pile of manure you
could also get some
a roommate possibly brian you could
possibly sell the car you're in new york
i don't know how much you need a car but
you can get creative and
thousand dollar car when you make 70.
you can get creative here
yeah let's go ahead and sell the car and
get a 5 000
car too and then let's start working on
these student loans after you move in
as as fast as you can but dude you have
to cut down to nothing beans and rice
rice and beans and you're going to clean
this mess up
and you need to quit making decisions
based on
you feeling trapped every time you
tell yourself you're trapped is right
before you do something stupid
all of us are that desperation precedes
stupidity
it has in my life my whole life every
time i can look back and go that's the
dumbest thing i ever did
it's always because i convinced myself
and my little brain
that i was desperate and you feel like
you are painted in a corner with two
options and you never just have two
options you have lots of you can get
creative and you have a lot more options
anything
i would love it dave if you would speak
to the whole renting versus buying
things i think that his thought process
though
a lot of people go through that of well
if i'm gonna rent i'm just throwing
money away
speak to the whole the the reason the
baby steps are in that order
of buying a home after you're out of
debt and it's not throwing away
money when you rent and do it in the
right order well because
landlords have to pay the bills and if
you're the landlord for yourself you get
to pay all the bills
people say oh well i can rent for x and
for even less i can have a payment
yeah even less plus or minus the heat
and air system you get to fix
plus or minus the hot water the heater
that goes out plus or minus the increase
in taxes
plus or minus the increase in in
freaking insurance yeah
plus or minus you get to pick up all the
big boy bills when you the owner
yeah and so this calculation people use
it's the same price to
rent as it is to own per month is stupid
because you do not know what you're
talking about you've left out all these
real world expenses of owning a home
owning a home is more expensive in a
given year
than renting the exact same home
right beside each other is more
expensive in a given year
to own it than to rent it in most
markets
now there's some exceptions but by and
large that's the case now where
homeownership comes into play is a
long-term view
but you can't do the long-term view when
you are broke
yeah well and i would imagine most
people going through this thought
process
are first-time home buyers they've never
bought a home so they don't know that
like you're talking about so they're
like oh
1300 1300 it's the same let's just put
it towards a house
it's not wasting money renting while
you're working a plan to get a solid
foundation under you is not wasted money
it's called patience
it's not wasted you're going to come out
ahead over a 10-year period of time
a 20-year period of time if you will
rent until you get out of debt and have
your emergency fund and then have your
down payment
and not be an impatient immature
and i deserve this and i'm going to go
buy a condo
because it's the same price and he and
your broke parents told you to do it you
know that's always great
and so um so you just you can't
you have to look at things long term
and then it makes sense to own a home
yeah and i'm a huge believer in real
estate i own a bunch of real estate
but the point is it's not cheaper in the
coming 12
in the coming 14 and you cannot afford a
3500
heat and air system when you're freaking
got car payments coming out your ears
sally may has their own bedroom you just
and this is what happens to people and
they go oh you know i thought renting
was cheaper
i thought owning was cheaper it's not
and so you gotta stay in it you got to
stay in it and think long term